tras dos meses de tensa calma vuelve la
violencia de las cárceles de ecuador'
esta vez los presos intentaron invadir
un pabellón con disparos y explosivos
pudimos constatar lo que estaba
sucediendo
cruces de balas muy intensos muy
cercanas a las puertas de ingreso a la
penitenciaría detonaciones
una situación de
salvajismo el motivo del levantamiento
es el enfrentamiento de las bandas de
narcotraficantes de la cárcel que luchan
por el control de la prisión el 28 de
septiembre en esa misma cárcel 119
reclusos fallecieron en una de las
crisis carcelarias más fuertes de la
historia del país tras ese motín el
gobierno ecuatoriano declaró un estado
de excepción para el sistema
penitenciario por 60 días soldados
apoyan a los policías para mantener el
control en las 65 cárceles del país ni
la policía ni los militares lograron
entrar nadie nadie puede tomar el
dominio de allá desde ese reciente
matrimonio de carne tu ponga la mano
dura señor presidente la gente que está
aquí no es perro
los motines carcelarios de ecuador han
dejado 250 muertos en lo que va del año
en la penitenciaría de guayas según
cifras oficiales hay más de 8.500
internos y una sobrepoblación del 60%
con un hacinamiento del 30 por ciento en
todas las cárceles del país el problema
carcelario sigue latente